I am not a bounty hunter
i've heard otherwise
i know that you sit on the
throne of your former employer
jabba ruled with fear
i intend to rule with respect
you were all once captains under jabba the hutt
i'm here to make a proposal
that's mutually beneficial
why speak of conflict when
cooperation can make us all rich
what prevents us all from killing
you and taking what we want
if you had spoken such insolence to jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie please
speak freely
Welcome back everyone star wars just dropped the
book of boba fett trailer will break it all down
is the mandalorian spin-off it's basically like
the mandalorian season 2.5 so it'll feature a
lot of characters from the mandalorian series
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i will be doing
full episode videos for this there's supposed to
be six episodes total obviously starting to air
december 29th i'll just start at the beginning
of this footage and go through shot by shot
talk about easter eggs wtf moments and what's
going on with the other characters and what's
going on with the mandalorian characters in
the mandalorian season 3. so just charting the
timeline this basically picks up a very very
short time jump after the end of the mandalorian
season two like not a lot of time has passed like
there was a little bit of a time jump for them
to go back to tatooine to jabba's palace after
grogu left with luke skywalker and r2-d2 to start
his jedi training in after denjarin mando went
with the darksaber the other mandalorians in moff
gideon in tow to take him to a new republic prison
so in that post-credits scene he comes
back to jabba's palace and basically kills
bib fortuna taking jabba's throne and taking over
jabba's criminal empire but is easier said than
done like you see him having these meetings with
jabba's former captains you could also make the
comparison to what happened to the empire after it
was believed that the emperor had died obviously
we know differently now power reports a vacuum
unless someone more powerful is able to come
along and bring all the captains to heal usually
the organization falls apart and everyone kind of
splits off into their own territory just grabbing
as much power as they can that's basically what
happened to the empire like maf gideon came along
and moff gideon was trying to rally what was left
of the empire but even though it seems like he's
going to be rotting in prison the empire we know
isn't going to fall apart because grand admiral
thrawn is out there to really rally the rest of
the empire around the galaxy we'll see more of him
during the mandalorian season 3 probably some more
teasers for him and then during the ahsoka series
that they're getting ready to film they also just
announced that hayden christensen is coming back
as darth vader and anakin skywalker for the ahsoka
series so i'll do a separate video about that at
some point everybody hoping for anakin and ahsoka
in live action they're gonna pay that off but they
actually start the trailer with one of the spider
droids from jabba's palace on tatooine because
most of the series seems like it's going to take
place in and around tatooine so this is a b-16
spider droid if you're not familiar with the lore
or you never read tales from jabba's palace it's
basically a brain from one of the B'omarr monks
inside a spider droid's body to help it get around
they're like an order of monks that try to become
very enlightened and shed their physical form so
they literally eventually take their brains out
of their bodies and put them on jars inside their
monasteries but when they need to get around they
just attach the canisters that their brains are
in to these spider droids so these are basically
just like mobility droids for the brains in
the jars then i'm assuming the ithorian that
he's talking to during the trailer who's asking
him about being a bounty hunter is some lesser
crime lord on tatooine like you see this giant
wide cityscape i think this is another city
somewhere else on tatooine that we haven't been
before he and fenik shan go to visit this ithorian
and he's asking him about being a bounty hunter
and when he said i'm not a bounty hunter i was
actually kind of expecting him to say i'm just
a simple man trying to make my way in the galaxy
but throughout the trailer they're just trying to
hype up boba fett going around to what was left
of jabba's criminal empire all the lieutenants all
the captains to try and hold them together within
the organization i think the droid handing him
his helmet is one of the pit droids from phantom
menace we also saw those during the mandalorian
season 1 and season 2. speaking of helmets you
also notice that most of this trailer features
him taking his helmet on and off in broad daylight
another big difference from the mandalorian series
with din djarin but they kind of explained that
during the mandalorian season 2 when he met bo
katan kryze and she kind of had to explain to him
no you're the crazy one we take our helmets off
all the time mandalorians do that all the time
and basically explain to him that he came from
this crazy zealot sect of mandalorians they kind
of implied during the mandalorian season one
that those were the death watch mandalorians
which bogotan was also part of for a brief period
where if they weren't the death watch bandalorians
they were a group within the death watch
mandalorians that broke off like extra hardcore
death watch mandalorians either way that was
just a way to show you in future seasons why
we're going to be seeing way more mandalorians
who all take their helmets off all the time
i'm not sure who's playing this ithorian crime
lord but the voice sounds kind of familiar
love the way all the regular townspeople here just
stare at him and fenix and as he walks by because
everybody recognizes boba fett's armor even if
they've never met him they know him by reputation
i also love that this ithorian crime lord has
a twilike serving him the same way that bib
fortuna served jabba who boba fett just killed
to take jabba's throne as the ithorian says here
i hear you sit on the throne of your former
employer because you just killed his assistant
who was also sitting on his throne not sure if
this scene of the big mexican three-way standoff
they're having is also inside another part of
jabba's palace or some other part of tatooine
but you see the gamorean guards in the background
in most times when you see gamorean guards in the
trailer it's inside other places of jabba's palace
that's another one of the big differences you see
with the way they film jabba's palace in this
trailer is they show all kinds of other places
that we never visited during the original trilogy
they're just trying to convey that it's a really
really big palace with a lot of different rooms
he talks about ruling with respect instead of
ruling with fear like jabba did trying to form a
more business-like relationship with all of his
former captains so amongst jabba's former captains
we have some tansdoshans here some Klatooinians
those are the ones that have the dog faces and
then some aqualish because we're on tatooine of
course they're gonna bring back the tuscan raiders
they feature them during season one and season two
of the mandalorian i think they're just trying to
show you how he's trying to be more rational about
this more business-like than someone like jabba
less impulsive like jabba during return of the
jedi sending everybody to the rancor because fenix
shand right after this mentions jabba's menagerie
which the rancor was part of jabba had a whole
zoo of all kinds of crazy exotic animals from all
across the galaxy but they do intercut separate
footage of him just going all ham on these other
guards in this other city with that club weapon
he was using during the mandalorian season two
to smash up the storm troopers so now i know a
lot of you are asking what's going on with the
mandalorian din djarin himself there are rumors
that he's going to show up during these episodes
like a cameo scene for continuity what's going on
with grogu and luke skywalker right now basically
groku has just started his jedi training there was
some promo art of him constructing his lightsaber
with luke skywalker using a yellow crystal and
its official promo art that lucasfilm released
so it definitely makes it sound like the next
time we see grogu or at some point during the
mandalorian season 3 or season 4 or during the
ahsoka series we will see grogu with a tiny
yoda sized lightsaber yellow crystals are
used by jedi who become jedi sentinels
jedi who balance their combat skills with academic
pursuits like academic jedi pursuits temple guards
also use yellow jedi crystals as well as far as
the plot with the dark saber and bokeh tan crees
the other mandalorians she's still trying to rally
more supplies more ships steal more back from the
empire to rally her forces so that they can retake
man to lower the planet back the way they set that
plot up during the mandalorian season two made it
sound like it was going to be the end game of the
mandalorian series like that would be one of their
big final battles against grand admiral thrawn
there is supposed to be a big crossover event that
all the mandalorian spin-offs are building up to
but they didn't say when that's going to happen
but din jaron still has to have it out with bo
katan kryze over the darksaber but now because
he possesses the darksaber he sort of has a claim
to the throne of mandalore even though he himself
doesn't want it it's very game of thrones jon snow
energy i don't want it so what'll probably happen
in the short term with bokeh tan crees in mando is
that she'll just use him as sort of like a puppet
leader but she'll be the one calling the shots
the whole thing with maf gideon is that he'll just
be chilling out in a new republic prison until
grand admiral thrawn's forces come to break him
out as far as the mandalorian season 3 episodes i
believe that they've started filming already so
they'll probably release those episodes around
this time next year but if you spotted any other
easter eggs or you have any of the big questions
about what's going on with the book of boba fett
episodes of the mandalorian just let me know in
the comments below and i'll try to add them to my
future bonus videos we're supposed to get the star
wars obi-wan kenobi episodes next year as well as
the star wars rogue one prequel series the andor
series so next year we might actually have three
separate live-action star wars series premiering
will you wait for everything everyone click here
for my brand new spider-man no way home first look
breakdown of the green goblin and click here for
my new spider-man morbius trailer video and easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!